madame la Présidente Monsieur le Premier
Ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues je
m'adressais à vous il y a un an et demi
au début de notre mandat en soulignant
la difficulté de la tâche qui nous
attendait je vous faisais part d'une
conviction celle selon laquelle nous
vivons un instant décisif de la vie de
notre pays force de constater que je
peux rependre ces termes devant vous
pour décrire la situation actuelle crise
inflationniste école crise géopolitique
crise démocratique nous sommes toujours
à cette croisée des chemins nous
assistons jour après jour à la
complexification du monde qui nous
entoure les défis à relever sont donc
toujours aussi
nombreux néanmoins et en dépit d'une
situation politique
inédite nous avons fait adopter plus de
50 textes tous nécessaires depuis
l'élection de cette assemblée nous avons
su trouver des consensus quand c'était
possible et des compromis quand ça
n'était pas les années qui viennent ne
seront utiles au pays que si nous fixons
un cap clair ce cap c'est celui d'une
France plus juste et plus prospère pour
le plus grand nombre c'est ce qui a
guidé l'action de chaque premier
ministre depuis 2017 et je veux ici
saluer l'action d'Édouard Philippe Jean
Castex et isisabeth
borne Monsieur le Premier Ministre les
espoirs et att de
sont immenses la tâche pour ne pas les
décevoir est d'autant plus
ardue comme avec votre prédécesseur vous
trouverez les députés du groupe horizon
et apparenté à vos côtés pour travailler
dans le sens de l'intérêt général
partenaire sérieux partenaire loyal mais
partenairire exigeant c'est ainsi que
nous concevons d'accompagner votre
action gouvernementale nous devrons
apporter des réponses rapides mais
pérenes sur plusieurs sujets
prioritaires que je me permettrai de
décliner dans la suite de mes propos
surtout ces solutions ne porteront leur
fruit que si elles sont de bon sens nous
croyons fermement que l'immense majorité
des Français souhaite en réalité de la
Justice de la simplicité et de
l'efficacité depuis quelques jours les
revendications agricoles nous rappellent
à quel point de nombreux Français se
sentent abandonnés dans l'époque qui est
la nôtre ils s'y sentent d'ailleurs pour
beaucoup d'entre eux parfois prisonniers
il désespère de la qualité de nos débats
publics et ne manque pas de nous le
faire savoir aussi je demande à chacune
et à chacun de sortir de ces certitudes
en regardant la France telle qu'elle est
et non pas telle qu'on voudrait qu'elle
soit l'actualité récente nous démontre
que la surtransposition de normes est
une bombe à retardement pour les
secteurs qui la subissent les
injonctions contradictoires le
dénigrement du travail les règles
imposées en dépit du bon bon sens font
le malheur de notre pays et en
particulier de notre agriculture si nos
sols et nos
savoir-faire sont une grande et belle
puissance agricole ne les prenons pas
pour acquis il nous faut à tout prix
éviter que l'agriculture française
connaisse un déclin similaire à celui de
la sidérurgie au siècle dernier nous
saluons donc les mesures annoncées par
le gouvernement elles vont dans la bonne
direction je dis cela sans renier rien
de notre engagement pro-européen nous
voulons bien sûr une Europe qui qui
s'affirme davantage sur la scène
mondiale une Europe au service de ses
citoyens mais aussi une Europe qui ne
crée pas de contraintte excessiv ni de
concurrence
déloyale la question de la juste
rémunération de nos agriculteurs
pourrait d'ailleurs se poser dans
d'autres domaines le travail doit payer
c'est une question de bon sens et c'est
même l'un des fondements de notre
contrat
social je pense à ceux qui cumulent les
heures de travail parfois les emplois et
n'arrivent pas à boucler les fins de
mois ce sont les mêmes qui souvent
ressentent une pression fiscale accrue
qui n'est pas compensée par les
contreparties offertes par notre système
social la société du travail doit être
notre boussole travailler dur doit
permettre à nos concitoyens d'augmenter
d'améliorer leur niveau de vie de telle
situation génère un sentiment d'absence
de considération auquel nous devons
remédier notamment en faisant en sorte
qu'il soit toujours préférable de
travailler que de ne pas travailler
cette considération il faut qu'elle soit
la même à Paris aussi bien qu'à carbone
à sevrant ou à aaco en garantissant un
accès au servicees public en luttant
contre les déserts médicaux en
désenclavant les territoire par une
offre de mobilité adaptée et en assurant
ordre et sécurité pour chacun la
mobilité c'est de pouvoir changer de
lieux d'habitation et de ne pas subir
une forme d'assignation à résidence or
la crise du logement est là et elle
n'épargne personne elle concerne d'abord
l'accès à la propriété avec des
acheteurs potentiels qui font face à une
hausse des taux d'intérêt et dans le
même temps une baisse des crédits
accordés par les banques initialement
créé pour répondre à ce besoin le
logement social ne tient plus sa
promesse républicaine c'est donc une
double peine pour la majorité de nos
concitoyens qui sont exclus des
logements sociaux tout en étant
confronté à des prix sur le marché libre
bien au-delà de leur capacité en un mot
la crise du logement nous oblige à une
réponse rapide global et de long terme
faire preuve de bon sens c'est aussi
investir pour pour l'avenir pour notre
jeunesse en poursuivant nos efforts au
service de l'éducation nos professeurs
sont aujourd'hui mieux rémunérés et nous
sommes rentrés dans une nouvelle ère
face au harcèlement scolaire celle de la
tolérance zéro mais beaucoup reste à
faire en particulier sur le plan du
respect de l'autorité de cette
institution et du corps enseignant je
sais Monsieur le Premier Ministre votre
attachement à ce ministère qui fut le
vôtre là encore vous pourrez compter sur
nous cette capacité à voir loin pour nos
enfants se traduit aussi par la la prise
en compte de l'urgence écologique dans
l'ensemble de nos politiques publiques
le cycle des événements climatiques
extrême s'accélère et trouble laquiétude
des habitants de notre pays au côté du
ministre Christophe Béchu nous prenons
une écologie pragmatique fondée sur le
réalisme et toujours de bon sens en
matière climatique comme ailleurs nos
arbitrages devront prendre en compte le
sentiment d'étau dans lequel se sent
pris une grande partie de nos
concitoyens nous devons être attentifs
aux conséquences qu'auront les hausses
inéluctables des factures énergétiques
et environnementale avenir les prochains
textes que nous serons amenés à voter
devront prendre cette réalité en compte
et permettre à la France de tenir son
objectif de neutralité carbone à horizon
2050 au-delà de la protection de la
planète et de la biodiversité je veux
rappeler notre engagement pour la
protection des Français en matière
militaire de justice et de sécurité
trois lois de programmation historique
ont été voté par le Parlement en un an
elle doent notre pays d'une trajectoire
claire concernant le fléchage des
dépenses dans des champs régaliens
stratégiques sur plusieurs années
modernisation de nos armées plus de
recrutement dans la justice plus de
force de l'ordre sur le terrain c'était
là des attentes de longue date du peuple
français nous veillerons également à la
poursuite de notre politique fiscale et
à la mise en œuvre dès 2025 comme vous
l'avez annoncé Monsieur le Premier
Ministre de la baisse de 2 milliards
d'euros d'impôts pour les classes
moyennes afin que le travail paye pour
paraphraser Jacques Chirac la feuille de
paix ne doit pas être l'ennemi de emploi
de là seulement naîtra la compétitivité
l'innovation et donc la prospérité les
députés du groupe horizon et apparenté
resteront toutefois vigilants sur le
fait que chaque dépense soit financée
afin de mettre un terme à la croissance
de la dette publique et ainsi préserver
notre souveraineté budgétaire et
financière sujet d'intérêt pour notre
groupe la réforme de notre système de
santé doit se poursuivre personne sur
ces bands ne peut se satisfaire qu'une
grande partie de nos concitoyens soit
privé d'une offre de soins accessible
dans un délai raisonnable le groupe
horizon et apparenté l'a déjà affirmé
c'est aux acteurs locaux d'organiser
l'offre de soin en fonction des besoins
de chaque territoire si la baisse de la
natalité nous inquiète à juste titre il
faut aussi se préoccuper du
vieillissement de notre population autre
grand enjeu de notre siècle la
proportion des plus de 50 ans est amenée
à doubler d'ici 50 ans ce n'est rien de
moins que la soutenabilité de notre
système de santé qui est en jeu pour
cette raison nous ne pourrons pas faire
l'impasse sur une loi dédiée au grand
âgees
l'année 2024 sera enfin et c'est
suffisamment peu courant pour s'y
attarder une année de révision
constitutionnelle je fais partie de ceux
qui pensent qu'il ne faut modifier la
Constitution clé de voûte de notre
République qu'avec une main tremblante
certains changements apparaissent
pourtant nécessaires compte tenu de
l'évolution de notre société la
consécration d'interruption volontaire
de grossesse comme droit garanti pour
toutes les femmes tout d'abord l'avenir
de la nouvelle caléonnée ensuite et plus
personnel le statut d'autonomie de la
Corse que vous avez évoqué lors de votre
discours monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le Premier ministre
vous l'aurez compris le groupe horizon
et apparenté souhaite que notre pays
retrouve du bon sens notre programme de
travail est chargé pour peu de temps
utile notre programme éclair soyons
efficac parlons de fond trouvons le
consensus faisons disparaître ce
sentiment de mépris source de notre
affaiblissement démocratique vous pouvez
compter sur nous notre groupe loyal mais
exigeant sera à vos côtés pour faire
réussir la France je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur le
président